aujourd'hui donc on a pu faire un point
je préfère qu'on peut à la fois de la
première vague et de ce qui est en train
de se passer c'est à dire cette deuxième
vague
au moment où je vous parle partout en
europe l'épidémie est en train de règles
c'est l'airé très fortement les chiffres
ont été rendus publics dans beaucoup de
pays membres de l'union européenne et on
voit une accélération extrêmement forte
le premier ministre ministre des
solidarités de la santé plusieurs autres
membres du gouvernement sont revenus
hier lors de la conférence de presse sur
en effet cette accélération de la
diffusion du virus
à cet égard les mesures annoncées la
semaine dernière renforcé hier sur le
plan graphique demeure extrêmement
importante je veux ici vraiment insisté
d'abord sur la nécessité de les
respecter et d'être nous tous et toutes
acteur que la réponse au virus nous
savons quand même vous comprenons mieux
le virus et nous pouvons tous jouer un
rôle en respectant les gestes barrières
les cinq fameux geste que nous avons
plusieurs fois répété en nous
appropriant l'application qui a été
annoncé hier pour aider au traçage en
continuant à bien tester et puis en
respectant les éléments de couvre-feu de
réduction des effets des échanges et des
contacts qui sont inutiles au fond
continu et d'éduquer continuer de
travailler au maximum
mais réduire un peu je sais fait partie
aussi du sel de la vie malgré tout
qu'est cette vie sociale pour aider à
freiner vous ce virus nous aurons en
milieu de semaine prochaine une vision
plus claire de l'impact des mesures que
nous avons pu lire
renée plus les plus structurantes
justement donc il faut encore attendre
et nous aurons des décisions à prendre
dans les prochaines semaines pour
ajuster les choses
d'ores et déjà j'avais annoncé que nous
soyons au moins pour six semaines
d'avoir ces mesures de couvre feu cette
réponse
la réponse que nous avons toutes et tous
en tant que citoyens la responsabilité
qui est la nôtre
elle est d'autant plus important ce
d'autant plus importante qu'il nous faut
faire corps avec l'ensemble d'épaisseur
de personnel soignant en mars avril on a
tous pris conscience de ce qui se
passait nous avons tous eu peur
nous avons tous vu compris le rôle
qu'avait toutes celles et ceux qui nous
soignent tout au long de l'année
la france entière a applaudi à 20 ans il
faut que nous reprenions pleinement
conscience de ce rôle et je le dis avec
beaucoup de force ça que je veux ici
aujourd'hui rendre hommage remercier
l'ensemble de nos personnes personnels
soignants mais aussi des personnels
administratifs techniques à l'hôpital de
ce lycée l'hôpital de composants noah et
res qui ont été très mobilisés
les agences régionales de santé joue un
rôle extrêmement important depuis le
début de la crise il ya aussi beaucoup
de personnel à la culture qui sont
mobilisées jour et nuit qui se sont
beaucoup donné la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie
mais je veux aussi saluer l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé dit de villers
aux professions paramédicales et toutes
celles et ceux qui sont aussi dans les
établissements médico-sociaux pas les
structures para médical que ce soit
d'ailleurs des structures dont que ce
soit du soin à domicile
ce continuum là c'est celui qui nous a
permis de tenir de gagner lors de la
première vague face au virus de résister
pleinement et c'est aujourd'hui à
nouveau toutes ces femmes et ces hommes
qui subissent la pression que celle
deuxième vague on voit les lits
d'hospitalisation mais aussi de
réanimation à nouveau augmenter donc je
le dis vraiment pour tous nos
concitoyens
il faut que vous y pensiez que vous nous
aidiez au fond et à protéger nos
soignants protéger l'ensemble de celles
et ceux qui sont là pour vous protéger
vous même en faisant ses efforts alors
nos personnels soignants sont confrontés
à une situation qui était
celle de cette remontée que j'évoquais
mais après avoir vécu la première vague
après avoir vécu la reprogrammation des
soins qu'ils avaient été annulés une
activité qui n'a donc passé c est donc
avec toute cette fatigue accumulée
aujourd'hui c'est aussi pour cela que
nous avons souhaité non seulement les
mesures annoncées lors du ségur en
juillet mais l'accélération de celles ci
avec une première partie des primes qui
était dès cette rentrée et comme le
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
a annoncé cette semaine une accélération
au mois de décembre
du reste justement des augmentations une
majoration de 50% ce plaisir
supplémentaire et une compensation des
congés qui sont annulés pour pouvoir
justement mobiliser nos professionnels
de santé nous allons faire face tous
ensemble et l'échangent qu'on a eus je
trouve a été pour moi extrêmement
extrêmement éclairant et je le disais
pas rassurant parce que nous avons
l'épidémie devant nous mais encourageant
parce qu'on a beaucoup appris de la
première phase et parce que ici de
manière exemplaire et mise en place une
organisation l'hôpital travaille avec la
ville avec toutes les structures d'amont
et d'aval et au fond c'est aussi
justement en partageant cette
responsabilité qu'on arrivera à mieux
répondre à ce défi
c'est à dire dès qu'on a été testé puis
diagnostiqués avec ce virus de pouvoir
aider les professionnels de ville à
mieux accompagner mieux prendre en
charge et prévenir des complications
ensuite faire en sorte que le maximum ce
sont donc des lits classique à l'hôpital
que et dans les services compétents que
ces personnes soient patients soient
prises en charge et de réduire au
maximum celles et ceux par ce travail
justement pour l'hôpital et la ville de
réduire 22 personnes qui arrivent aux
urgences il y en a malgré tout
continuera à en avoir parce qu'on voit
ralentir effréné mais je veux rendre
hommage à tout ce travail qui a été fait
et du côté justement de noces murs de
nos samu
l'accélération en termes d'organisation
qu'on a réussi en première phase avait
dit on à vous avez inventé ce dont on
avait rêvé
qui sont ces fameux service d'accès aux
soins et en travaillant je dirais une
manière beaucoup plus efficace doit
aussi transversale sein de l'hôpital
avec les autres services mais aussi avec
les partenaires de la sécurité civile
des associations et de la ville
de réussir à ce que la prise en charge
la plus adaptée la plus rapide possible
pèse moins sur des structures
hospitalières
même pendant un temps est soit beaucoup
moins difficile pour les personnes qui
étaient ainsi contaminés est-ce qu'on a
acquis là on est en train de le à
nouveau de le redéployer non le gardera
au delà de l'idée donc c'est là dessus
que je veux finir
moi je veux ici redire notre
détermination à continuer de transformer
en profondeur notre système que soit
notre système de santé français
c'est une fierté il a été conçu et a
maintenant un peu plus de 60 ans dans la
forme qui est la sienne
mais l'héritier d'un modèle historique
il était fatigué à cause des réformes
qui parfois n'avait pas été fait à cause
aussi du manque de moyens et il y avait
beaucoup de tension on le savait mais
tout le monde a pris sa responsabilité
dans cette poule 1 de manière exemplaire
et le cdur comme je le disais cet
investissement inédit qu'on va faire un
peu plus de 8 milliards chaque année
dans les années qui viennent
les investissements qu'on a aussi décidé
doivent être au service de ce projet est
un projet au fond d'un meilleur
accompagnement des patients et aux fonds
de meilleur accompagnement de tous nos
citoyens pour prévenir beaucoup mieux qu
on le fait en france pour accompagner
des la ville où les structures hors de
l'hôpital à l'hôpital puis après
l'hôpital et donc être au service de ce
décloisonnement que j'évoque voilà les
quelques messages que je voulais vous
passer après cet échange extrêmement
riche que nous avons lu et je veux
vraiment remercier le directeur
l'ensemble des chefs de service et et
médecins cadres de santé qui était avec
le directeur général de l'agencé
régionale de santé moi même ce que vous
aviez imaginé que ce que deuxième vague
pourrait être aussi importante
martin hirsch évoque la possibilité que
cette deuxième vague soit plus violente
que la première
aujourd'hui on en a appris un silence
qui sont 270 via l'application 66
est-ce qu'à la fin il va pas falloir
durcir encore nos conditions de vie est
ce que vivre avec le virus c'est
possible escales afin de soulager les
saunas il n'a pas falloir tout
simplement reconfirmé comme on l'a fait
la première pas alors d'abord nous
étions dans l'anticipation je le
rappelle on a préparé le déconfinement
entre le 13 avril et le 11 mai en ayant
différents scénarios et tout de suite
en s'engageant sur les stratégies
potentielles de reconfirmer le conseil
scientifique avec l'ensemble de l'équipe
qui était dédiée à cela avait présenté
préparé avec eux nos équipes partout en
france les stratégies d'ailleurs taux de
réponse il ya une deuxième vague est
donc une reprise de l'épidémie
donc nous avions préparé ces scénarios
qui peuvent aller jusqu'au recours
seulement locale ils ont été là aussi
documents expliqué mois de juillet donc
on peut pas dire qu'on a été surpris par
cette hypothèse elle existait elle était
dans les modèles et nous savions de
toute façon que sauf heureux hasard liée
à des effets d'échos système c'est à
dire des effets climatiques des choses
qui arrivent dans les virus et qui font
qu'un virus parfois s'arrête en fonction
des saisons de tel et tel changement des
conditions là les heureusement je le
redis une manière très simple nous nous
débarrasserons du virus un soin par
chance et beaucoup d'éléments que
maîtriseront pas mais je crois que la
chance n'a pas été avec nous cette fois
ci était arrivé avant d'autres virus va
se muer en soit si nous avons une
immunité collective d'environ 50 à 60%
de la population se rappelle qu'après la
première vague nous étions à 5 à 6 % en
deux ans semble loin et ne voulons pas
cela parce que c'est beaucoup trop
dangereux pour le pays
avec des conséquences profondes au delà
de la mortalité évidemment des
conséquences graves
tous les âges de la vie puis la
troisième option c'est d'avoir un couple
vaccin traitement qui est staline et
donc c'est évidemment comme ça que nous
nous en sortir et donc nos horizons
c'est celui d'avoir des traitements on
en a beaucoup parlé il ya des
traitements qui commence à exister pour
stabiliser en tout cas des protocoles
qui se développe il y en a plusieurs
on améliore les choses on prend mieux en
charge au début on arrive à ce qui est
moins de gens qui aillent directement
réanimation on arrive à moins un tube et
de natation fin au grave on arrive à ce
qui est moins de mortalités on doit
continuer ce travail et à côté de ça on
continue le travail de recherche au
niveau international pour avoir un
vaccin le stabiliser mais plus testé
l'effet secondaire et avoir ensuite une
stratégie vaccinale qui permettent de le
déployer tout ça je veux dire aux
françaises et aux français fait que
quand j'écoute les scientifiques ces
scientifiques et je veux dire que vous
n'étiez pas en désaccord
on m'a parlé on voit bien qu'on se
projette au mieux jusque à l'été
prochain
la question c'est comment justement
vivre avec le virus dans cette période
dans la phase où nous sommes nous
n'avons d'autre choix compte tenu du
nombre d'infections par jour que de
freiner
c'est à dire de réduire notre vie
sociale au maximum limités des contacts
pour casser sa circulation
on va continuer je testais d'alerté
protéger on va continuer d'améliorer le
traitement de ralentir défendent grave
mais si on veut vraiment préserver notre
système de santé et nos principes et on
est obligé de faire ça donc on va
évaluer chaque semaine
l'efficacité des mesures prises et
toujours un effet de décalage et donc au
moins jusque début décembre nous aurons
tout ce qui a été annoncé par le
gouvernement et ces mesures mine de
manière certaine je peux vous dire
aujourd'hui n'ont pas vocation à être
réduit mais elles seront peut-être
renforcer si elles ne sont pas
suffisamment efficaces de deux manières
soit en s'étendant géographiquement
comme il est soit en regardant aussi les
lieux
les moments où faune l'épidémie se
propage de plus vite pour réduire à
chaque fois ces occasions et on va
essayer de le faire de la manière la
plus ciblée et donc il est trop tôt
aujourd'hui pour dire si on va vers des
confinement locaux large
on va essayer à chaque fois d'aller en
quelque sorte réduire les lieux les
moments où on a identifié que le virus
circule est bon c'est cette stratégie on
va sortir dès qu'on aura suffisamment
freiner la circulation du virus
c'est à dire qu'on sera revenu environ
3000 à 5000 qatar joue c'est à peu près
à ce niveau là qu'on sait qu'on peut
faire on créa d'après adopteront une
stratégie différente
il va consister à réouvrir en
intensifiant les tests le système d'
alerte et le système de d'isolement de
protection parce qu'on sait que si on a
un système beaucoup plus efficace on est
en train de faire l'application vous
remercie de l'avoir cité au säntis
qu'ovide est un élément important le
fait qu'on teste de plus en plus on est
un plus d'un tir de 6 millions de qx
rester par par semaine en ce moment on
est un des pays d'europe et est le plus
on va continuer de monter en charge tout
ça on va développer le psg ni d'autres
formes c'est la stratégie vers laquelle
on ira dès qu'on aura suffisamment
entraînés et à ce moment là vous voyez
bien qu'on pourra reprendre certaines
activités qu'en ce moment on a arrêté
parce qu'on sera encore mieux répondre à
la chose
voilà donc je veux ici donné des en
quelque sorte déjà non je vous dis la
vérité
les prochaines semaines seront des
semaines on doit tous faire un effort
pour nos soignants et pour freiner le
virus mais avec la perspective sion fait
cet effort collectif suffisamment
efficacement de continuer à vivre avec
le virus mais en relâchant ses
contraintes
parce que on fera mieux le tester alerte
et protéger et on devra alterner entre
ces stratégies
à chaque étape en nous améliorant et en
étant plus efficace en réduisant la
pression sociale
vraisemblablement parce qu'elle était
proche et l'allemagne
elle espère pouvoir commencer à vacciner
dès la fin de cette année vous dites que
au gnouf on pourrait espérer avoir une
maîtrise de l'épidémie
cet été alors pourquoi ne pas espérer
aussi en france un vaccin plus traite
alors on peut avoir
on a en ce moment plusieurs vaccins qui
sont dans une phase des trois c'est à
dire qu'ils sont dans les premiers
essais on sait que certains ont commencé
à le faire donc on peut tout à fait en
fin d'année début d'année prochaine
commencé à avoir des vaccinations qu'est
ce que ce sera une stratégie nationale
qui permet de répondre virus je crois
que c'est trop tôt pour le dire et c'est
peu vraisemblable
et donc nous aurons des éléments ou dans
un cadre quantifier on pourra commencer
à tester des vaccins stabilisé mais on
ne pourra pas déployer une stratégie
vaccinale vraisemblablement si vite
je crois que il est plus raisonnable je
dis avec beaucoup de prudence et chose
parce que avoir beaucoup d'humilité on
ne sait pas tout je ne sais pas tout on
a parfois nourri des espoirs sur des
traitements ont maintenant sur des
vaccins
et puis on s'est aperçu que ça ne
fonctionnait pas totalement par
définition c'est quand les tests
cliniques sont encore en cours dont 60 à
stabiliser on peut penser qu'on aura
plus de visibilité à la fin du premier
trimestre 2011 21 je crois que c'est une
perspective est plus sûr c'est aussi
pour ça qu'après nous sommes 66 millions
d'habitants si vous voulez avoir une
stratégie de vaccination qui est
efficace et qui freinent le vaccin c'est
pas juste commencé à vacciner qui
freinent pardon le virus
c'est pas juste commencé à vacciner
c'est être sûr que vous vacciner entre
20 et 40 % de votre population pour que
les choses commencent vraiment à voir un
arrivé en vacciner des millions de gens
pour la grippe et vous aura pas échappé
que ça fait des décennies qu'on a
stabilisé un vaccin contre la grippe que
malgré cela malgré le fait qu'il ya peu
d'effets secondaires qu'on ait maîtrise
très bien et qu'on le connaît eh bien
vous avez entre 35 et 40% simplement des
gens qu'ils ont d'avoir cette année
donc voilà il ya tout ça qui est à faire
mais on a des perspectives
on a des vaccins qui sont en phase 3 il
ya partout dans le monde des tests qui
sont en train d'être fait des essais qui
sont en train d'être fait on fera
évidemment le plus vite possible et sur
ce sujet-là j'insiste sur un point
notre stratégie est européenne c'est à
dire que nous européens nous sommes mis
ensemble pour financer des programmes de
recherche communs nous avons des
industriels de plusieurs pays et des
experts français comme vous savez qui
sont marqués mais indépendamment de st
nour pain nous sommes mis en situation
de pouvoir produire les doses de vaccin
quel que soit le laboratoire
il est découvert le vaccin plus efficace
ou non que ce soit aux états unis en
angleterre en chine ou ailleurs et donc
on aspire structurer un accord mondial
pour que ce soit un accès un accès
mondial et un accès public
quel que soit le laboratoire ils
truquent nous européens nous avons prévu
les capacités de production en
mutualisant les choses pour que dès
qu'on a quelque chose on puisse produire
en masse un européen est évidemment
protéger nos populations et qu'ensuite
aussi on puisse protéger des populations
de pays plus pauvres qui en auraient
besoin
par une stratégie de solidarité donc là
dessus c'est vraiment une approche
européenne et nous avons re merci
beaucoup merci vraiment à l'ensemble des
soignants et ils vont accueillir une
autre
il s'agit de bêtises
[Rires]
les tableaux de bord
après
on est triste
m
tél
ouais on reste ici
[Musique]
mais la fouille à la télé bougez que tu
autour
je reviens branché pour passer
[Musique]
j'avais pas je me suis